al'approche dabakh au d'immenses
d'inondations puis les ruines de la
ville de marche à rebours en
cornouailles et notre atterrissage est
un exercice délicat pour éviter l'eau
c'était l'aéroport principal mais il y a
eu beaucoup de dégâts et tout est sous
l'eau
cet avion vient évacuer des malades ils
attendent depuis trois jours et certains
sont hagards au le tout a été pulvérisée
quand quelque chose comme ça vous arrive
vous faites ce que vous devez pour tenir
jusqu'au point où capituler vous vous
dites il faut juste que je m'en sortir
tout autour des voitures et des
bâtiments soufflés des routes couvertes
du déluge de l'ouragan et des arbres
décapité dans le seul bâtiment en dur
qui reste un camp de fortune et une mère
de famille qui sans patiente
vous semblait épuisé oui je veux juste
sortir d'ici où étiez-vous pendant
l'ouragan enfermé dans un placard j'ai
dû quitter ma maison est trouvé refuge
chez quelqu'un d'autre nous traversons
les pistes guidés par le bruit de trois
avions de secours qui viennent de se
poser on a pu emmener 50 personnes
aujourd'hui mais il n'y a plus de
lumière sur la piste je ne peux pas
attendre quitter l'enfer de l'après
ouragans
le refuge est à 30 minutes d'avion de
marche à rebours